President Trump announced this afternoon
that he'll be pulling the United States
out of the Iranian nuclear deal three
years after President Obama negotiated
it the president has promised to kill
this deal for a long time he talked
about it a lot on the campaign trail he
won the election so no one should be
surprised that he did it when the deal
was created it was negotiated by the way
by two groups Iran and the Obama State
Department neither of which had
America's interests at heart so it
started to feel too sad about the death
of the deal so you have to wonder what
it means will it take America closer to
war with Iran and if it does are we
prepared to fight that war or does it
make lasting peace more certain Michael
Anton was a national security official
in the Trump administration he's just
reentered the private sector and he
joins us tonight
Michael thanks for coming out hey thanks
for having me so this is certainly no
defense of the deal which I took as a
matter of faith was negotiated in bad
faith and not on behalf of American
voters but you've got to kind of wonder
here ambassador Bolton goes into the
administration in almost immediately
there's a missile strike against Syria
and the Iran deal is scuttled he has
said repeatedly that he would like
conflict with Iran so the question is
only moving toward that I think just the
opposite in fact what the Iran deal did
is it gave the Iranian regime a windfall
first a cash windfall and then a
business windfall yes by lifting
sanctions by allowing countries that
have long wanted to do business with
Iran back in Germany especially the UK
France all started enacting commercial
contax contracts with Iran we've seen
the Iranian GDP go up and Iran's
spending on ballistic missiles on terror
financing on destabilizing activities on
continuing wars in Yemen in Syria all of
that rose since the Iran deal went
through by reimposing sanctions which is
what getting out of the deal does it
will reduce the amount of resources that
the Iranian regime takes in and it will
reduce their ability to spread mayhem
and chaos and it will reduce conflict in
the likelihood of war conflict with the
United States because I think maybe at
the core of this is the question I
understand that Iran is a rogue nation
and doesn't like the United States but
if you were to list a server hierarchy
of nations that threaten us would it be
on that list oh absolutely it's one of
the top nations
that list it's been the axes been
raining in sponsor terror of we had in
this country last say 20 years in the
last 20 years well there were in this
country harder to say but against US
interest if the Iranians have either
backed or been involved in there have
been many they blew up a dormitory in
Saudi Arabia the Khobar towers as before
in this case 1996 that killed almost 100
Americans they probably we believe
trained and maybe even provided the
explosives to the al Qaeda terrorists
that bombed the embassies in Tanzania
and Kenya we know the 9/11 Commission
showed that they facilitated transit for
the 9/11 hijackers bin Laden's own son
lived in Iran for a time bs documents
that were captured when bin Laden's home
was raided in Pakistan that the Obama
administration refused to release
because it would paint a very dark
picture of Iran and harm the possibility
of getting the deal the Trump
administration finally released and it
shows Osama bin Laden on the record
saying to his followers you got to work
with the Iranians they hate the
Americans as much as we do this is a
necessary and useful alliance even if we
have our differences there are the Great
Satan and you know we basically agree
with that we can we can work out a
little differently that's a compelling
data point I would agree with that I
think it's really interesting it hasn't
received enough attention McMaster
though was for keeping the Iran deal
correct my my know stating that and I
think your misstating that I think I
think that there was a consensus in the
administration that the deal was bad we
would give our European allies a
reasonable chance to fix it the
president agreed with this and the
president said it in his January
statement if people can come together if
these nations can come together fix the
flaws he'd be open to staying in what
you saw the action here today is that
that didn't happen and look I would say
to the critics who were say that the
president Trump was always eager to get
out of the Iran deal he certainly was I
think he heard to get out of it or fix
it but it's telling that we're now what
16 months into this administration and
he didn't do it on day one no you're
absolutely right he gave every chance to
all parties to come together and see if
he could make this thing better and I
think 16 months is plenty of time it
didn't happen and he kept to his word
Michael Anton make you the case thank
you very much thank you